so you're not into the whole Disney what  they're doing you know the woke stuff  that this is what they do hasn't Disney  always been woke I mean my favorite  Disney movie when I was a kid was about  like a middle eastern dude which was it  I didn't even know what he was I thought  Aladdin was white some brownies  like yo When We Were Young it was like  Mulan a lot I even know there was white  people  there was one white it was like Arielle  was like a fish and white yeah mermaid  she was white and white people the best  swimmers like that makes sense  yeah so it's like I I always thought it  was diverse I don't know why everybody's  making a big deal so you're saying  Disney's been woke for a while I would  even call it woke I think it's woke when  you like virtue signal about it like  nobody when when [ __ ] Aladdin came  out nobody was going oh here they go  trying to capitulate to the Middle  Eastern people